[Musique]
un faux intox c'est avec Anthony
Saint-Léger et sur Twitter comme sur Tik
Tok Anthony de nombreuses vidéos à sont
devenues virales la raison un insecte ah
oui depuis le 13 septembre beaucoup de
vidéos en circuler la plus ancienne elle
nous vient de Tik Tok que voit-on et
bien on voit un homme qui déplie les
ailes d'un insecte vert qui porte cet
insecte vert sur ce sur son dos sur son
abdomen plutôt ce que certains ont
identifiés comme étant un numéro 36 ou
38 et 7 légendes en russe les gars
pourquoi savez-vous d'où viennent ces
chiffres sur ce moustique cette vidéo
elle nous provient de ce compte et elle
accumulé regardez plus de 12 millions de
vues ce n'est pas rien et elle a été
très reprise sur différents comptes
beaucoup d'internautes ont identifié du
fait de ce numéro c'est un sac comme
étant un moustique génétiquement modifié
de quoi faire dire à certains donc qu'il
permettait de transmettre des maladies
mortelles et à moindre coût il y en a
aussi qui ont fait un référence à Bill
Gates s'agit-il des moustiques
génétiquement modifiés de Bill Gates
nous dit celui-ci ou encore celle-ci en
néerlandais pourquoi y a-t-il des
numéros sur ces moustiques génétiquement
modifiés alors pourquoi justement cette
référence à Bill Gates c'est bien on va
revenir un petit peu plus tard mais
d'abord expliquer nous comment montre
réellement cette vidéo et bien pour
répondre à ces questions à cette
question la rédaction des Observateurs
de France 24 a contacté deux
entomologistes de spécialistes donc de
l'étude des insectes et ils sont
unanimes ils ont évidemment visionné la
vidéo et elles sont unanimes il ne
s'agit pas d'un moustique écouté Johanna
Villeneuve Chazey qu'on a pu interviewer
même en quelques secondes on voit que
ils sont en train de remonter les ailes
deux pairs donc déjà on voit que c'est
pas qu'une paire d'elle donc déjà tout
de suite ça montre que c'est pas un
moustique on peut voir que c'est un
puceron notamment par la forme des pâtes
et notamment ce puceron un des petits
dessins caractéristiques sur l'abdomen
qui pourraient faire penser à certaines
espèces de pucerons alors vous entendez
l'entomologiste qui a utilisé le
conditionnel elle n'est pas catégorique
pas sûr à 100% pour la simple et bonne
raison comme elle nous l'a expliqué
qu'il faudrait pouvoir l'identifier sous
microscope mais en tout cas l'espèce de
pucerons semble correspondre à le
séraphys betulae que l'on voit ici et
dont l'une des caractéristiques
justement c'est la présence de tâches
naturelles noires sur l'abdomen de
l'insecte qui pour certains vous le
voyez pourrait faire penser à des
chiffres comme ici le 8 mais sur
d'autres n'ont rien de particulier donc
si apparence de chiffres il y a ce n'est
qu'une coïncidence alors pourquoi
certains ont-ils associé cela à Bill
Gates et bien parce qu'il y a bien un
lien entre Bill Gates et les moustiques
en l'occurrence des des initiatives
financées par la Fondation Bill et
Méline dagate déferme à moustiques pour
lutter contre la propagation de maladies
comme le paludisme ou encore la dengue
transmise donc par des moustiques par
exemple cette initiative en Colombie
récente Bill Gates en faisait l'écho sur
son blog le 15 août dernier où il s'agit
et bien d'élever des moustiques porteurs
d'une bactérie spécifique pour empêcher
de de propager justement les maladies
tropicales et de les transmettre à
l'homme l'idée est ensuite de les faire
se reproduire avec des moustiques
sauvages pour justement limiter cette
transmission alors ces projets ils sont
loin de faire l'unanimité en témoigne
par exemple celui mis sur pied au
Burkina Faso c'était en 2019 le le
forçage génétique la modification
justement génétique tout comme le manque
d'information des populations locales a
été très critiquée à l'époque par les
ONG merci Anthony Saint-Léger c'était un
fond intox restez avec nous prochain
journal dans trois minutes sur France 24
[Musique]